[Musik]
das motto mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video für euch mal wieder aufgewacht
sollten videos einwänden und darauf
reagiert übels korrekt wirklich geiles
video israel schickt mir videos an
irgendwas kann ruhig dürfen sie
irgendwie irgendwas und dann schickt er
mir einfach eine straße muss ich
wirklich sagen beschweren kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger es ist auf
jeden fall sehr lustig zunehmend jahren
anders zu schmeißen wenn man kann sich
zu machen nach im leben im alter
[Musik]
sowas habe ich mehr respekt und war
natürlich kann man sagen das ist einfach
eine übung also man natürlich ein
gewisses musikalisches verständnis aber
übungen dann kann jeder klavier und
keyboard spielen eigentlich dass viele
halt auch nicht wissen ist dass ich
tatsächlich ein talent hören war kann
ich ja ich weiß jetzt gar damit
gerechnet ich kann mit meiner nase auch
tired of the caribbean spielen also hier
schaut euch das mal an was bleibt mir
auch ein keyboard gekauft und wollte
lieber shoppen köln ich bin mir derzeit
selber wieder ein bisschen tiefer
spielen bei deswegen wenig megacool
solche videos zu sehen und ja beste
video
bisher hatten check mit ihrer katze und
der check ist dass ihre köpfe aneinander
machen alter freunde wie gold ist es
mittel wenn man ein haus die harten
kommen beispielsweise nach hausen hat
seinen eigenen scheck mit dem haustier
natürlich mit bestimmten freunden hat
man verschiedene schecks somit dem einen
macht man vielleicht diejenigen die mit
dem anderen er somit einfach nur die
hand genauso wie man die hamburger aber
stellt euch vor ihr kind und sie kommen
nach hause
jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt weil er
da und herren wasser dieses mädchen
rausgefunden einer studie zufolge hat
sie etwas rausgefunden freunde ich bin
gespannt wann kann es nur sein ist ab
juli ins geschäft die apotheke
gelacht habe ich daher weniger befüllt
ist ein talent aber die habe ich selbst
gemacht es ist auf jeden fall ein talent
also als im internet wächst im kalender
diese zahlen hat halt einfach jedoch
entscheidend also du hast diese kopien
verwendet gemacht wenn die gruppe jedoch
nicht darstellen soll dann nicht so ganz
gut geworden
[Musik]
an der stelle muss ich wirklich sagen du
hast seiner freundin hier eine
pusteblume einfach in den mund gesteckt
blum ist dann vielleicht irgendwo am
straßenrand und dort haben von tiere
drauf gepinkelt oder keine ahnung was
damit schon fast ihr dahin noch gäste
daran davon keine dran und so was muss
ich wirklich sagen wenn ich so was wir
werden eine menschen im mund gesteckt
wird das ist auf jeden fall lustig mal
ordentlich gemacht bei den nächsten
video hat mit ihren die mir das
eingeschickt hat gesagt dass sie ihre
kleine stofftiere anbei helium mit
helium gefüllte ballons gehangen hat
damit die kap fliegen konnte in seoul
awp das ganze geklappt hat
die wirklich sagen geklappt hat dass ihr
eher weniger freunde format blu klappt
reagiert gibt es jetzt auch schon in
italien also das format gibt es nur in
deutschland
aber er will die tage und sagt mir das
video auf italien geschickt da muss ich
wirklich nichts mehr zu sagen eigentlich
total beschissen das video du kannst dir
da überlegt man hat keine wirklichen ton
aber ich bin verdammt nochmal alpaka
also redet nicht es in alfacar das
besetzte videos wie kann ich überhaupt
noch macht dich reden warum man freunde
ich will diese ganzen video wo leute
irgendwelche haustiere mit den
haustieren irgendwelche sachen machen
ich will auch sagen viele immer wieder
hunde haben will
irgendwann bin ich dann irgendwie wesen
und beeilen
ich habe jetzt auch kekse dann endlich
die denic de weck das beispiel aber
jetzt wird weiter hey ich kauf mir im
fußball und fußball spielen danach weil
man keinen bock mehr fußball spielen das
kann man im fußball halt einfach
irgendwie weg legen und dann erst in
einer woche wieder aus und wenn man
wieder beispiel hat in meinem haustier
muss man halt immer irgendwie behauptet
immer irgendwie da deswegen ja nicht
mehr sehr vorsichtig bei solchen
entscheidungen das nächste video was für
ein geschickt wurde meine lieben freunde
ist ein video wo ein junge wie ich ein
junges kind tolle youtube wieder nach
rechts auf einem sportplatz ich würde
sagen
also erstmal vorweg das wie photoshop
von apa red wer kennt nicht die leute
sind eigentlich ein seit bekannt ich
muss sagen dass dieser junge das
wirklich sehr sehr schlecht macht
tatsächlich noch schlechter als abu raed
in dem video aber die scheibe weitergeht
weil in der nächsten szene kommt jetzt
sein kollege auch noch mit rein
man muss dann wirklich mal überlegen die
leute die die videos sind auf dem
sportplatz die sind vielleicht zehn
jahre alt und dann läuft sein vielleicht
kleiner bruder oder kleiner freund
dadurch die jetzt vielleicht weg und
macht so und reicht ihr [ __ ] muss
ich wirklich sagen die erziehung hat da
auf jeden fall richtig gut funktioniert
bei den kindern in der schule kein
beispiel an solchen leuten also wie
immer freundlich vor allem und jedem was
ich irgendetwas wir da und jeder weiter
mit dem leben also freundlichkeit ist
immer so dass dort wo eigentlich in
jeder situation ich weiß was ich selber
meinen videos häufig mal beleidigt ich
glaube jeder weiß dass das bei mir eher
aus spaß gemeint ist also warum soll ich
fick dich so dass sich andere ja keine
ahnung dass andere beleidigt und er
tagtäglich photoshop war ein job ich war
da nicht mal hell scheiße er war dunkel
bei forschungen
ich weiß nicht ob meine bachelorarbeit
geschrieben habt ihr fällig gehen die
jetzt am dienstag seine muskeln
ich wollte mit den grössten pc sondern
irgendwie angeht mit man muss nicht ich
bin einfach dünn bei mir sieht definiert
aus so das ist gar keine frage ich bin
hier kein fitness kanal oder in die
antwort aber wenn du schlägst muss
zumindest meine schuhe haben dreimal
mehr als dein geburt gekostet ich fick
dich in welcher wie teuer seine geburt
ein paar sekunden später ich habe
nachgeschaut und wenn man bei einer
krankheit versichert es wird eine
stationäre geburt übernommen von der
krankenkasse das heißt eine stationäre
geburt tatsächlich kostenlos also kostet
60 euro fällig falls diese korrigiert
nicht gerne den kommentaren hab ich mir
daher grob gegoogelt schnellen euro das
heißt wer deine schuhe dreimal so teuer
sind wie beispielsweise meine geburt
dann muss ich wieder an 300 euro sind
krasse treter alter ich wusste ich sagen
wenn ich solche videos vom deutschen
leuten die einfach willkürlich leute
dies nun einfach voll so helga
videoinhalten und da denke ich mir
wirklich mich werden kann ich mich da
normalerweise das machte die familie da
und dort gefallen lassen
das schaffen wir
mit einer 13 millionen like das heißt
ich würde sagen und 40 millionen hoch
gegriffen sagen wir mal gang soll noch
am meisten geleistet video sein ich sag
mal zwölf millionen 14 12 millionen sagt
allen leiten damit wir das schaffen und
schreibt alle luca reagiert in die
kommentare wenn ihr wollt dass luca
reagiert mache weil ich mache das
eigentlich nur wenn ich jemand eltern
will noch nicht weiß was ich machen soll
intern richtigen stationären pc ihr habe
und ich hab ich habe mich war das stativ
hier findet ihr die eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf können in einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren dadurch verpasst
sich keine videos mehr dort findet auch
nicht auf eingeblendete wegen des
neuerdings unter anderem fisch zu kaufen
gibt becker neue t-shirt und hier unten
meine damen und herren dort befindet
sich ein weiteres video was ihr euch
jetzt anschauen könnt